Now let's take a closer look at what happened with Apollo 13.
The rocket is already in a parking orbit around earth.
To take us to the moon, the rocket is fired again,
this will result in such a trajectory.
This phase here is called "translunar injection."
This trajectory is a so-called free trajectory.
It's going to return safely without the astronauts doing anything about it.
So in case anything breaks, they are going to return, no matter what, just by gravity.
The first thing that happens was planned, namely, to get rid of the rest of the rocket,
which eventually crashed on the moon.
The second thing was planned as well.
A midcourse correction, MCC.
The objective was to take the spacecraft to a trajectory that's closer around the moon,
but there was a price to pay.
This trajectory no longer was a free return trajectory,
but eventually they'd not return to earth.
So that is an unsafe trajectory.
Which everybody learned somehow was after that
when one of the O₂ tanks exploded.
Now the spacecraft had to be taken back to earth
as quickly as possible.
The solution was to fire the rocket again.
This maneuver was called DPS-1 for distant propulsion system.
The rocket that has been fired
actually was the rocket that was intended to safely land on the moon.
This has to be fired in such a way that we are taken back to a free return trajectory
and eventually return to earth.
What's going to occupy us this and next unit
is how to compute the right amount of acceleration
the spacecraft needs at this point in time.